what else you got okay so you have h q
so H two died H is obviously yeah I
thought like it could have been cool I'm
like they could be like jeopardy
jeopardy is huge so if you don't know
what HQ was it was a mobile app it was a
game show like Wheel Fortune jeopardy
whatever but that was all done on a
mobile app which was when I saw this
product some our friend Eric who does
tribe socks he showed me this happen he
was like dude my friend went to go work
at this company it's really interesting
check this out he pulls it up so at 6
p.m. every day they would do the game
show so you get a notification at 6 you
open the app there's a host a live got
you know live live game show host on
live streaming and he would ask trivia
questions that you would push the button
and you have 10 seconds to answer you
push the button real quick to answer if
you got all 10 or 12 questions right
you'd win the prize at the end which at
that time it was there was 400 players
and the prize was like $500 this thing
grew like crazy they had games with over
a million concurrent players and exactly
over a million players and over I
believe they had over a million dollars
in prize money over time and so this
thing had this run and they got tons of
funding founders fund funded them ten
million dollars in funding at a hundred
million dollar valuation and then they
had big-time brands launch stuff on
there so they were like you know this
game is sponsored by Nike it's all
trivia about athletes and we're gonna
drop this shoe the new shoe released
it's happening live on HQ and that's the
prize they were doing some interesting
stuff but it was kind of a fad and which
everyone knew which everyone knew
because it was like games all have this
hype cycle and then this decline over
time they're not games aren't super
super sticky most of them and this was
definitely that so those big novelty
grew like crazy viral product in many
ways as somebody bakes products was very
inspiring because it was like so simple
yet so awesome right I actually fully
product there I'm not trying to be
hyperbolic but I felt like there was
some revolutionary things for sure it
was like oh I'm looking at the future
this is this is what the future looks
like I still think that's what the
future looks like
HQ dot for many reasons socotra
calendars are so literally one founder
died he overdosed on drugs the other
founders they were sort of always
infighting they were both sort of like
kind of come across at least from the
outside as a sort of like moody artists
yeah
one of them I believe started fine also
Russ yeah yeah both of them they are
both the founders of vine so definitely
sort of brilliant guys in in a way but
everyone says that Russ is a dick yeah
in the and he had he got removed a CEO
because he had some problems you know he
was a dick or whatever the other guy got
removed also never figured it out and
the the game show host Scott became this
kind of like cult sensation cuz he was
the host everyone saw him every day and
he tweeted out when it shut down
recently he was just like this company
died for one reason alone and that's the
sort of incompetence and arrogance of
the founders and I was like yeah damn
that is like you don't usually hear that
like everybody so PC and always just
worried about the career know he's a
comedian he ain't give a [__] yeah he
definitely did not give a [__] cuz that
was that's pretty brutal on the day that
he shut down let's say can I tell you
what I would do yes okay so I would I
have no idea if they did this job I
would have built this knowing that it's
going to die and so it's like it's my
thing is I'm gonna be a hit machine
right and I'm gonna use this formula and
I always thought about this with
remember like cronut yeah okay you know
how like these viral food things like
these food things go viral I like one
day sat down I'm like what makes them go
viral so it's and I've like broke it
down to a handful of categories which is
like it's either of it's gotta be a food
that's typically aside but you're gonna
eat it in excess so for example only
cookie dough and set it so ice cream
that's just cookie done right or make
the shot you make the topping the main
yep so like one formula you could use
yep another like or like fondue so likes
fondue is typically an appetizer
fondue only right another thing is you
take the shape of it and you make it a
ridiculous shape yes
easy including small to big like there's
Bob's Donuts is your sizing so you make
something small big big small right the
the fifth or fourth thing is color
rainbow Raggles so you just take the
color green ketchup Instagram a bowl yes
yes and then I had a fifth one which was
some mashups which is cronut right Kris
oh yeah and then that was the fifth one
you took their Doritos locos taco one of
them the most successful fast-food thing
in like the last 10 years was this
Dorito locos taco and then every
fast-food chain hired these eight
I used to be like find me the next
Dorito and so those are the five like
categories that I discovered and then
it's like okay so you just make it go
viral by you you have to have
distribution via Thrillist BuzzFeed and
then eventually it's like well you just
have your own handle and then yours
might be okay and they're gonna have a
small shop outside outside in Brooklyn
or in Manhattan and you're just gonna
you're always putting out bangers yeah
you're just gonna [__] knocking out
the parking you're gonna have a line all
the time and then three months later ooh
that one shut down switch now we're
doing cookie dough ice cream every
season you come out with a new one viral
sensation yeah it's like alright now
we're to love this we're doing rainbow
cake now or green ketchup and hot dogs
like you just like is like okay it's so
if I was I've always thought about like
that's the way to go you just have a
small you just are paying and you're
banging these out and then for the ones
that last hour hits like Crona it might
be a hit I mean that's kind of like its
own category now then you've that's like
you're one of your tempo franchises
right it's always available yeah that's
what I would do and it's so with HQ
trivia I would've on the same thing this
is like supreme for food it's like you
have this limited scarce kind of like
out there thing what you're doing is
you're making these these sort of wild
concoctions on the food side using these
five different yeah but it's all
formulaic yes it's just like all in one
of these five formulas Zynga and then
you do a limited edition drop you
basically say you know you tweet out at
1:00 a.m. it's live you get a huge line
people cover the fact that there's a
line and then it becomes a thing in a
hipster town yeah this is so easy like
Bagel Bites like pizza and bagels so
this is went back when you were doing
your hotdog stand if you knew everything
you know now but you still needed to do
hot dogs in you would end up doing
something more like this like green
ketchup like that are my stick to catch
up with only be green right and what I
did back then was I had what I did was
like you just have a little shtick like
mine was my onions
I would boil them in coca-cola which a
lot people do I would just tell everyone
I did that right and so there's this is
actually a famous copywriting trick
which is have you ever heard of um a
time like a watch like a like a
wristwatch being described as like with
quartz movement yes they all have
[__] quartz movement right they all
do
all of Abdul or like space-age aluminum
they all that's not even a thing first
of all like what's that madman
it's like our filters are rolled or
something like yeah and they're like
well everyone's is and they're like well
they don't know it right so space-age
aluminum that that means nothing first
of all all right first of all nonsense
yeah it's a quartz movement every single
watch has that right and so the idea
here is you just take something that
they don't know even though all the
insiders know you just tell them right
we did this experiment when we were
doing the sushi restaurant where we took
the descriptions of our food so it'd be
like you know you take a Philadelphia
role which is like this Americanized
it's salmon it's cream cheese and it's
cucumber in a sushi roll and then we
would just so Dan Ariely was one of our
advisors and he's the guy wrote
predictable and so he would he told us
like hey one of the reasons wine charges
this premium is because they created a
whole language around what they do you
need to create a language around sushi
so that people who start to learn about
it feel like they know more and now they
want to pay more so they can have the
better thing just teach of what is the
better thing and so we would you know we
started just adding words as one
experiment we would have one version of
our website where it was all online
ordering so is one version of our
website would be the normal website then
our a B test was the other variation was
our Philadelphia role would be called
like we called the Philadelphia role and
then the description would be like
Atlantic fresh you know never frozen
salmon with you know Philadelphia
Philadelphia Cream Cheese and a finely
sliced cucumber and we would raise the
price and we would get like more orders
even despite the higher price that's
crazy and so this is like a
psychological thing around yeah that
[__] works yeah around the descriptions
around things okay back to HQ for a
second so they did try to release other
games they came out with like a word
scramble type game I think they kind of
ran out of time and also they had built
the hype too much and less until we
learn when you build this much hype if
you start to fail you death spiral way
faster cuz the height the pressure of
your expectations and hype will crush
you well so that's what I mean is I
would have built this company in
networking that like we discussed that
clog it and they're like well they're
building it so it they're gonna just
capture all the value upfront and then
let it die right so if you were to built
that right Oh like built that into it it
would have been it could have been a
company kind of like I imagine saying it
does this which is they just have like
they're like alright this game is only
in the last 80 days maybe
right so two quick ideas on this HQ
thing so HQ died okay you know rest in
peace but two things I could do if you
wanted to make make use of this of the
insights that were found in this I think
you can do this on top of twitch or
YouTube or any live streaming platform
that already has audience so you don't
need to be your own app you should just
host create a channel that's hosting a
show and give away the prize money and
promote it in the same way and so I
think somebody could build this on top
of one of the existing platforms not
enough to build your own tech and not
have to acquire downloads of your app
which is really expensive and I think if
you just did this every day at 7:00 p.m.
on Twitch I think a bunch of people
would turn in second idea around this is
maybe a the HQ format which is this live
video streaming with this charismatic
host and question and answer could be
used in education and so I would love to
see somebody create an after school game
that parents actually pay $3 a week to
subscribe to where your kid learned
science through some Bill Nye the
Science Guy type of host and it's trivia
it's interactive and they get sort of
points as they say I've thought about
starting that company but I really think
that that could work I think it might
also have the sort of fade and interest
but I remember as a kid I loved brain
quest and I played all these like
learning games and they were great and
so I think this is a modern-day burr
that's interesting that is quite sticky
I think that as we get older I mean your
kids not old enough so you'll imagine
you'll learn this once she gets old
enough but these things that we use as
we're your kids were just huge yes huge
I'm into that and you wouldn't need tens
of millions of people because you're not
advertising you'd be on subscription
because parents would be like oh I don't
often go drop my kid off at tutoring and
I don't have to like learn this myself
my kid already wants to sit in front of
the iPad all day so okay here's an iPad
game that I feel good about because
you're learning it's kind of cool
because it's live and interactive and I
could play with you and I'll pay three
bucks a week for that do you want to
hear what I've been in that same
category that I'll come back with some
more research but I was just surfing
around and saw is that but for allowance
okay tell me more so a friend Ramones
kid had I was like I was like hey Victor
allowance does your dad give you
allowance like he better be giving you
some money right and he goes yeah but
it's all in this app
like what do you mean he's like well it
is automated and I get $10 a week if I
do everything and I have a list of
everything I got to do and then it just
sends me this $10 but it sends it into
an account and I could use those on the
the places that he's already approved
that I could spend it on or if he wants
I can get this debit card that it only
works at a handful of places that's a
great idea yeah I was like of course
that's obvious that's a horse idea I get
mad at myself for not thinking of it so
I'm gonna go I haven't thought I haven't
seen their financials or anything I've
done I'm going to yeah
[Music]